it's really hard to get like one movie
star
to be in a movie um you managed to
basically assemble hollywood to be in
the film
so i am curious how many compromising
photos do you have of people
to pull this off none i have none
um i i it took a long time to put the
cast together probably was
just coming off of good time you know uh
wasn't batman yet um
and uh he was just an amazing actor that
i had the good fortune of knowing and
mia was another actress that i just
knew and and tom um i met through
uh through his agent and
um he had been cast as spider-man but i
hadn't seen him yet spider-man hadn't
again
uh he might have shot it or had been
shooting it but but i hadn't seen him
yet as spider-man so
i just got to meet tom holland and i i
thought he was an incredible
presence and i had seen his work from
earlier
and i just thought he was a great actor
and so you know it's it's
a very long process but this cast
together also what a lot of people don't
realize is the importance of scheduling
which really can dictate who is in a
movie or who is not in a movie i know
you had chris evans
and he had to back out because i believe
of scheduling
yeah it was it was unfortunate chris was
it was really lovely and
uh you know but we got really lucky um
sebastian's stan was is wonderful
in the movie um and it was
so game to dive into this character and
gain
a ton of weight really fast in order to
to take on this
the body type that that i had imagined
for bodecker
um yeah but scheduling is is scheduling
is like
part of making a movie it's like you
don't learn that in film school they
don't they don't do a class on
scheduling but it is
it's like half of your job is trying to
figure out how to schedule
actors into a film
i've heard this from so many people that
um that literally like a one week change
in a schedule of the shoot can
you can lose your whole actor like your
lead actor
yeah yeah it's very it's it's a game of
jenga
completely i'm always curious about the
editing process because it's the final
rewrite
um this has a you know this is many
different ins
like i don't want to uh chapters if you
will so i'm curious
like for example how long was your
earlier cut like how long was your first
cut of this movie
uh very long very long i mean uh the
very first cut of the movie was
probably around four hours
or so um maybe
maybe three hours and 45 i don't know
something like that it was it was uh it
was really long
you know what we actually didn't end up
cutting a lot of scenes we
kind of figured the part was part of it
was sculpting
figuring out what moments from some
scenes worked into the into the
in the movie um yeah and you know some
story i mean the the storyline that i
i'm um that i want to stuff that i want
to share the most is like stuff with
pokey lafarge's theodore that's a lot of
that stuff got cut out
and that is some of my favorite stuff in
them that didn't make it into the movie
most of my favorite stuff that we shot
but it was a very
it was a long delicate process of
sculpting my wife
is my editor sophia super caso she's a
fantastic editor and and loves puzzles
and this is a puzzle to put together
completely was obviously when you say 3
45 or 4 hours that's like your assembly
cut with everything in it
that's every single frame of the movie
put together
completely but you must like the movie
right now is about two hours 15 minutes
did you originally have like a cut that
was say 245
that you were super happy with you know
like a cut like
no no i never had a cut that was like a
really long cut
that i was like this is the cut and then
somebody said cut it it was
it was that was never length was never
really part of the conversation
um it was really like what is the what
is the
movie and then let's just make the movie
you know so
there's not like uh there's not like a
two hour 45 or two hour 30 minute cut
that i think is
is the ultimate cut of the movie um but
uh um but yeah i mean
no no i mean i can understand why
someone might think that but
it was like there was a there was a
rough assembly
and then there was a lot of sculpting
and wiggling and everything to get to
this cut
it was never like oh there's a better
cup than this sure well
the thing about this film obviously with
your cast there's so many fans of the
people involved
one of the things i've noticed about
netflix is that they tend not to release
deleted scenes
um is there obviously you have deleted
like deleted stuff from this movie
have you had any conversations about
releasing any of that or is it
sort of going to be you know um m.i.a
no i we haven't talked about it actually
um
but um i i i would love to i
um i would love to do that i mean
there's just a lot of stuff
even even even like the extended uh
version of
of of the church singing scene which i
think is a really beautiful
performance uh from pokey lafarge and
harry melling
um but uh no i'm
now that you mentioned i'm gonna go
check in with netflix
don't really do these
because they obviously have the ability
to give you deleted scenes they have the
infrastructure
it's just they don't typically do it um
and i i often think that you know people
would like to see an extended version if
they're a fan of the movie or
deleted scenes or yeah i mean
i always find that what's interesting
about deleted scenes
and then you see them and you go
yeah that didn't need to be in the movie
uh for people that are filmmakers
especially
it's so interesting to see a deleted
singing and to understand
why it was taken out you know like that
is i think i was
beyond just sort of like getting a
little bit more insight into the
character maybe or
just seeing more of the scene that you
really liked it's interesting from a
process perspective sort of like well
how do you
make these decisions and and why do you
choose
you know to cut out when you do
completely
how early on did you know you wanted to
have the narrator
and uh have it be donald
um relatively early uh my brother and i
we didn't write the first draft or the
first sort of draft and a half with
with uh the narrator in we uh
we we we knew that we were probably
going to use a narrator
um but uh
but we wanted to sort of let that happen
organically like we had talked about it
very early on
um but we we wanted to sort of write the
script without a narrator
and then see where we needed it
got it um i already have to stop million
other things i'm just gonna say congrats
on the movie
i hope it's a huge